calme sous tension ainsi peut-on on
vient de le voir s'exprimer à propos de
la nouvelle calédonie à la veille du
vote de demain
le ministre des territoires et
départements d'outre-mer monsieur
bernard pons à quitter le territoire et
apparemment les indépendantistes du fln
ks n'ont pas l'intention de troupes les
de troubler par dont la journée du
scrutin tout de même les forces de
l'ordre sont en état d' alerte maximum
françois corner mission spéciale
aujourd'hui en nouvelle calédonie pour
les pelotons de gendarmerie mobile
l'escort jusqu'aux bureaux de vote dans
les points les plus chauds notamment
ceux de la côte est de la grande terre
des représentants de l'état comme ce
fonctionnaire qui embarque ici dans un
verger un véhicules blindés à roues de
la gendarmerie
chargée de surveiller le scrutin de
transmettre à nouméa par radio les taux
de participation à différentes heures de
la journée et les résultats du vote
ces représentants de l'état seront
présents dans toutes les mairies leur
transport par engin blindé illustre bien
le climat de tension qui règne ici
après laffaire d'ouvéa et à la veille de
ce deuxième tour être transportés comme
ça avec des engins blindés
ça fait un drôle d'effet pour la
sécurité est rien
vigilance et précaution deux consignes
données aux forces de l'ordre pour
assurer sur la grande terre et sur les
îles le déroulement temps la légalité de
l'élection présidentielle à l'heure où
bernard pons qui était aujourd'hui le
territoire pour paris les centraux au
commissaire délégué du gouvernement tous
les pouvoirs en nouvelle calédonie les
escadrons de gendarmerie eux faisaient
mouvement vers les bureaux de vote pour
assurer demain leur protection
deux mille sept cents gendarmes ont été
mobilisés pour cette mission
l'ensemble des unités de la gendarmerie
et des autres armées ont été mises en
état d' alerte en nouvelle calédonie